welcome to the top 20 worst lines of
dialogue in game of thrones
for most of these rankings i'll be
judging the lines off of stupidity
contradictions cringe factor delivery
the person saying it and if the line
even has a point to exist in the first
place
with that in mind we have number 20.
does he like it gentle
or rough
as you can tell we're starting out very
strong with a terrible attempt at comedy
from euron greyjoy and you may be
thinking if this is at the bottom of the
list then it must be looking pretty grim
for the rest of the rankings
however for this line it's mostly just
cringey and stupid to the point that it
completely discredits euron as a
menacing character and makes him seem
like a laughable and comical villain i
would say this line would be worse if
euron was set up as a more serious
villain but that's not the case and
timmy this line is the highlight of the
worst aspect of his character it is a
short line but a finger in the bum has
gained the status over the years as
being one of the most repulsive lines in
the show and it's become a meme within
the community
number 19. there is land in the reach
goodland make it your own start your own
house with the unsullied as your
bannermen this is obviously a very
stupid proposition but at least it's the
thought that counts despite the
unsullied having no way in furthering
their succession given that you know
they physically can't reproduce
it's just really silly that one of the
smarter characters in the show made this
massive oversight in his pitch to
appease the unsullied also this is
basically just davos trying to bribe the
unsullied with something they clearly
don't want in an attempt to distract
them from killing jon
feels bad davos he made it all the way
to the end of season 8 until david and
dan wrote this stupid line for you
number 18
i'm the man who killed jimmy
i know i said the finger in the bum was
one of the worst you're on greyjoy lines
but this one tops it ever so slightly
because it's just flat out insulting on
top of it being cringe as well
the delivery of the line and that smug
face that euron proudly displays just
makes me want to punch my tv screen but
at least jaime didn't die from the stab
wound and instead died to bricks which
is also a very anticlimactic way to die
just thank god it wasn't directly from
this homeless degenerate it really
bothers me knowing that euron died
arguably one of the happiest people in
the show with the false notion that he
killed jaime lannister
number 17
you're the lady of winterfell you
deserve it we're standing here because
of you the battle was lost until the
nights the veil rolled in
now this line is by no means disgusting
but it's just straight up idiotic
it really tilts me that in this line jon
says that they won because of sansa
meanwhile in reality they almost lost
because of sansa by her not telling jon
about the veil
that and i mean john did the vast
majority of the work in the battle and
sansa rode in at the very end and
cleaned up the kill it's really
saddening to me that jon isn't
absolutely angered by this and instead
thanks sansa which is completely wild to
me he should have yeted harass over the
wall they were talking by for the
treason she committed
number 16
you want a good girl but you need the
bad [ __ ]
ah yes the classic line that made
everyone fearful of david and dan's
writing ability since this is one of the
first dreadful lines in the show's
history it really came as a shock to a
lot of viewers because before then there
was nothing comparable to how bad the
dialogue was in this single line we went
from george r martin's intellectual
writing and extensive use of literary
devices to david and dan's repulsive
nonsense like why did they even write
this line it serves absolutely no
purpose other than being cringe on top
of the line portraying the sand snakes
as being horny tweens on a quest to have
sex with brawn
truly a low point for season 5 and the
first red flag for how bad the writing
can get in the later seasons
number 15
i wanted those elephants
this is one of the briefest lines on the
list but to me i think it does a lot of
damage
now this is firstly a poor example at
comedic relief and the reason why i'm
including this in the line isn't because
of the line itself but the character
who's delivering it the fact that cersei
one of the most serious and strict
people in the show is now making quips
like in marvel is flat out jarring and
character breaking and i know dave and
dan try to pass it off as comedy but it
literally adds nothing of value other
than a cheap slapstick joke to the start
of the scene
when did cheap humor turn into one of
the core traits of game of thrones
it completely goes against her character
and it immediately paints her as being a
less menacing villain in a season where
she already has nothing to do
if you were to add a laugh track after
her saying that line it easily fits
i wanted those elephants
[Music]
number fourteen
now varys ashes can tell my ashes
see
i told you
so in a nutshell tyrion rambling
complete nonsense
like what the hell even is this line of
dialogue what kind of garbage is
entering my ear canal
now varus ashes will tell my ashes see i
told you
tyrion are you okay man
and honestly looks like peter dingles is
traumatized from the pure dog [ __ ]
quality of dialogue dave and dan has
given to him to say throughout season 8.
this is such a completely random line
that doesn't necessarily insult or upset
me but it just flat out confuses me as
to why it exists
number 13 maybe it really is all [ __ ]
in the end
so before going into this line most [ __ ]
jokes are pretty terrible lines but most
of them are delivered by characters who
are more reserved for comedy like brawn
and euron
but the fact that jaime is delivering
this line really makes me lose hope in
the show
what an outstanding writing technique
that david and dan have developed a
motherload of [ __ ] jokes so yes jaime
maybe it really is all [ __ ] in the end
number 12. i don't want to see the city
burn i don't want to hear the screams of
children burning alive no it is not a
pleasant sound
i i don't want to hear it
this isn't just one line but more of an
exchange between two supposedly smart
characters
one initial big issue with these lines
is the objective they're trying to
achieve
cersei has clearly made up her mind and
is a really stubborn character so the
fact that tyrion even proposed to try to
convince cersei to surrender is a lost
cause
then we get to the actual exchange
between qyburn and tyrion and what
tyrion says has to be the most
unconvincing thing he could have
possibly have said
his main point of persuasion is i don't
like this and that really this is coming
from the character that could feasibly
talk himself out of any scenario in the
earlier seasons and that was the best he
could come up with
you would think that tyrion would at
least make a good case for them to
surrender and this would be a scene he
could finally show off his intellect but
yet again david and dan drop the ball
number 11 everywhere she goes
evil men die
and we cheer her for it
and she grows more powerful and more
sure that she is good and right
this is basically david and dan using
tyrion as a mouthpiece to justify the
mad queen arc for daenerys you're
telling me that dany snapped because
people were cheering her on for doing
the right thing like there is absolutely
nothing wrong with the nurse killing the
masters in the calls because they were
genuinely bad people she was liberating
and saving slaves or breaking people out
of a toxic culture by killing those
villains
in other words she had a pure and
innocent objective and killed the
obstacles that were in her way of
achieving that objective
now when you apply this to the
destruction of king's landing her
objective was to liberate the people
from the tyrant cersei
but for whatever reason daenerys decides
to blatantly kill the innocent people
she was trying to save
like she actually has no reason to burn
down the city of king's landing it
doesn't serve her objective at all it
would only make sense that she burns
down the right keep to kill cersei and
in the process killed innocent people as
collateral damage so the fact that
tyrion gives such a stupid reason as to
why she acted the way she did i think
easily deserves an 11 spot
number 10
take this and go
i don't know how to use it
sticking with the pointy end i think
that is single-handedly one of the
stupidest slings anyone has ever said in
the show and there is a lot of
competition for that honor you're
telling me that sansa the girl who
survived and overcame cersei ramsey and
littlefinger can't wrap her head around
using a simple knife like sure if she
was handed a bow and arrow then that
would be understandable but a knife
really
there's only one simple way to use it
and the fact that arya had to say stick
him with the pointy end was just a
cringy callback
also this line that arya said in the
episode prior did not age well after
this interaction
she's the smartest person i've ever met
number nine i don't really want anymore
this singular line has to be one of the
most contradictory lines to ever grace
television the fact that david danced up
this notion along with bran saying this
i can never be lord of anything and the
three i draven and then the reveal at
the end of the show that brandon indeed
want to be king of the six kingdoms
makes me lose brain cells
did david and dan forget these lines
were in the script when they wrote the
ending was bran lying this whole time
did david and dan just want to subvert
our expectations by randomly picking
bran as the king
it just doesn't make any sense when your
character clearly says something and
then acts in a completely opposite
manner the textbook definition of
character breaking
number eight
what you like down there what
that's not your concern tyrion saying
this line to jaime is the most
disgusting and abhorrent thing to ever
come out of his mouth did tyrion
actually think that jaime would have
answered this question
he's literally just spewing garbage out
of his mouth for the sake of being the
quote unquote imp
but that also confuses me because why is
tyrion suddenly reverting back to his
more perverted mindset all of a sudden
it can't be because he was drinking a
little bit because he drinks in
practically every scene he's in
the only reason i can see david and dan
making tyrion say this line is to
randomly change the topic to jaime and
brienne having sex so that when braun
walks in he can say something funny
about it but in the process i feel like
david and dan utterly degrade tyrion as
a character and at the same time is
extremely disrespectful to his brother
someone who he values the most
number seven
and i know a killer when i see one
i take back the stupidest line title
from sansa not knowing how to use a
knife and i now gladly give it to arya
saying the most obvious thing in the
world thank you arya it only took
daenerys to destroy an entire city for
you to make that groundbreaking
realization of her being a killer
then again she has a pretty hard time at
spawning killers given she was snuck up
on by the wave as a suspicious old lady
but hey give arya her time she's a bit
slow coming to conclusions just overall
the sheer audacity of arya saying this
line after what just happened is like
slamming a pan into your face after you
went through a traumatizing event other
known as watching the destruction of
king's landing
number six
there's nothing in the world more
powerful than a good story
nothing can stop it
it shocks me that david and dan think
that this is some kind of massive
revelation that makes a great king
the delivery of tyrion saying this line
makes it sound like this is some
groundbreaking trait for a king that
we've been missing all along but no
it really doesn't matter that much the
fact that you of all people think that
stories are the most important factor
for a king when you are tywin's son is
very depressing
ah yes a good story is more important
than being benevolent strong motivating
and having wisdom it's about having all
those qualities and more which is why
varys was so obsessed with jon being the
king
purely an unintelligent take from tyrion
who does not fail to disappoint in the
department of brain power
number five
at least your balls won't freeze off you
take great defensive torches but love
telling unique jokes why is that
because i have voles
and you don't
[Music]
funnily enough these lines were so
damaging to the point that i put the
overall moment of this exchange as the
25th most stupid moment in the show
which is hard to do because the moment
is purely dialogue driven and nothing
happens that affects the story
but the dialogue on its own is so
offending to the characters saying them
that it thoroughly upsets me
not to mention that these are the
opening lines of the season what a
magnificent first impression david and
dan thank you it sucks that tyrion and
varys relationship has devolved into a
degrading wasteland of [ __ ] jokes
especially since their duo was arguably
one of the best in the show for seasons
two three and four but any intrigue
ahead left for this pairing is instantly
shattered with his opening line and
makes me just want to shut off season 8.
like how can people re-watch this season
when that is the opening line of the
season what a joke
number four i told you i don't want it
it doesn't matter what you want i don't
want it i don't want it daenerys is our
queen she shouldn't be you are my queen
i don't know what else i can say
you are my queen
while she she
is my queen i'm cheating a little bit
with this number but there is no way i
couldn't not put john saying the same
two phrases all season for these lines
on their own they aren't bad and are
just a very bland response that you can
give if it was said once or twice then
it would have been whatever but the fact
that in almost every scene jon snow says
i don't want it or you're mcqueen has to
be the most lazy writing in the show
it's mind-boggling to me that this
season took dumb and dumber two years to
write but they're over here copy and
pasting lines from different scenes
also this bland response that is used
excessively completely ruins jon snow as
a character
he becomes a hollow pit of a human when
this is the deepest his dialogue really
gets that's why these lines bother me so
much not just because of how poorly they
are used but also the fact that it kills
my love for jon snow
number three
why do you think i came all this way
i know most people would probably put
the sign as number one but to me the
next two are worse
anyways bran sang this line after going
an entire season of saying he doesn't
want anymore and that he can't be lord
of anything is the biggest contradiction
in the show's history
that smug little smell he gives after
the delivery of the line makes me want
to drop kick him out of his wheelchair
also this line raises a lot of questions
in terms of what bran meant
so does this mean that bran can see the
future and that is why he came all this
way if that is true then did bran let
the destruction of king's landing play
out was there no better way to get to
the outcome of season 8
my only conclusion now is that bran was
selfish and wanted to become king and
this was the only set of events that
could make that happen
which would again be contradicting
because he came across as the least
selfish person given that he didn't want
anything unless he was lying i guess i
don't know anymore my brain is imploding
in on itself trying to decipher their
horrendous writing from dumb and dumber
number two
if not for yourself if not for her
and for every one of the million people
in that city innocent or otherwise to be
honest i never really cared much for
them innocent or otherwise
i think it's really impressive that
david and dan were able to ruin a whole
character arc that was built up the
entire show with a single line of
dialogue
wow
the amount of incompetence on display
here is truly breathtaking do they not
understand jaime at all as a character
one of the best scenes in which jaime
tells brienne the truth of him killing
the mad king and how he cared about the
innocence is butchered now
again this goes back to the two years of
writing of season eight and the fact
that this is the best that diamond
number had to offer really makes my
blood boil look how they massacred my
boy
number one
and who has a better story
and brand the broken
the reason why i think this line is the
absolute worst is that it both doesn't
make any sense and that the primary
climax of the show hinders on this
single line and it fails so badly when i
was watching this live i literally
bursted out laughing the fact that bran
having the most interesting story is the
determining factor for being the king of
the six kingdoms is brain dead i can
maybe see bran as a king but the
reasoning for it is not there chief
out of all the characters to choose from
bran definitely has the most boring
story his story was so exciting that
david and dan didn't even include it in
season 5.
if they didn't turn him into a doll
piece of dirt that had no emotions and
cared about nothing then sure maybe he
would be a good king but bran in his
current state is by no means a good king
considering that he potentially let
king's landing get destroyed by daenerys
since he alluded to seeing the future i
wouldn't want someone as king who is
that selfish and is willing to let
unimaginably horrible things happen to
get what he wants
by that definition brian is a psychopath
if tyrion actually took the time to
listen to other people's stories besides
just bran then he would have been like
never mind dude your story is a
snoozefest in comparison to arya's
journey
but overall tyrion's logic for
determining a king is more than just
being idiotic it's downright offending
to the intellect of how smart the show
used to be
there it is those are my top 20 worst
lines of game of thrones
initially i also wanted to do the 20
best lines of the show but i feel like
that would practically be an impossible
video to make because of the sheer
amount of good lines that exist
that and to do the best shot possible i
feel like i would need to rewatch the
entire show to find any hidden gems and
that would take a very long time
but regardless though if this video does
really well then i'll definitely
consider it and let me know if you have
any suggestions for ranking videos or
what your least favorite line in the
show is thank you for watching